[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
talking about the issues that matter to
you the most
tonight the headlines about the NHS are
increasingly alarming more than 7
million waiting for treatment people
dying because of ambulance cues and a
social care system in disarray
and that's before we've even mentioned
strikes
year after year we shake our heads and
say surely this can't carry on but after
so many crises is the nation losing
faith in the Health Service I'm Trevor
Phillips and this is the great debate
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines
NHS bosses are saying they're more
worried about this winter than any other
patients aren't getting the care they
deserve despite the Health Service in
England being given an extra 6.6 billion
pounds one of the few public services to
be protected by the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt
nurses could be joined by ambulance
Crews Porters and Junior doctors on
strike
there are even plans to bring in the
Army to assist on the front line
Mr Hunt has asked Health bosses to think
carefully about how to reform the Health
Service but what exactly would this look
like faced with this scale of crisis
tonight as ever our viewers panel from
across the country indeed across the
world they'll have their say they'll
share their stories
and joining us in the studio this week
are
Chief strategy officer for NHS England
Chris Hobson
the head of the ippr's flagship
Commission on health and prosperity
Chris Thomas
columnist and author Simon Jenkins
and professor of global Public Health at
Edinburgh University Davey shrida
tonight we're discussing the NHS crisis
and asking
is it Beyond cure
can carry
carries breaks to the super rich
to get a doctor's appointment you can't
deliver for the NHS unless you have a
plan for the economy and he doesn't have
either Mr Speaker the NHS the NHS the
entire NHS industrial action in the
health service for new figures from NHS
England Administration and decision
making in the NHS hundreds of thousands
have sat in the NHS NHS leaders writing
to the chancellor there's so much
pressure and demand on the emergency
departments people have died and all
you've done is enough when people ask
what my priorities are for the NHS then
supporting the workforce in his first
amongst those Pilots
the nurses have been driven to this by
the government and that's a badge of
shame in the last 10 years Healthcare
staff have taken the brunt of the
posterity measures a lack of Staff gaps
in rotors it's wrong that nurses have
been driven to this stage the priority
for me is to continue the dialogue with
the trade unions with the RCL
[Music]
let's begin as always with our viewers
and talk to the wall the viewers panel
and I'm going to talk to Debbie Lenten
Debbie I think you're in Plymouth hi hi
Debbie what's your thought on this issue
I think it's a very sad State it's got
to to be quite honest
um the pandemic's been going on now for
a few years and we've obviously got to
live with this situation so I feel they
should have
um employed more stuff years ago before
we got to this crisis to be honest
um volunteers we should be getting those
in get the get the qualified staff from
abroad if we need to
um but it shouldn't have got like this
people can't get to doctors we can't get
the Medics out it's a terrible State
really
um and I really think it's time for a
change because it's just got worse on
that Debbie you have a question for our
panel
I do so my question of the panel is why
is the NHS in this crisis
thank you very much Debbie lenten's
question for our panelists why is the
NHS in crisis
Chris Hopson you've been there and
you've been on both sides uh
representing the organizations that
deliver as well as now working with NHS
England why
well so we know that the NHS is
currently under a huge amount of
pressure we know we have issues in terms
of we don't have enough capacity in the
NHS which is why we're putting in an
extra 7 000 beds or bed equivalents for
the coming winter we know we do need to
ensure that we have the right Workforce
which is why we're very pleased that in
the Autumn statement the chancellor
announced that we would have the
long-term Workforce plan that we've all
been asking for and we also know you've
already referred to it Trevor the degree
of pressure that the social care system
is under and Health and Social care are
two sides of the same coin and we know
that if social care is under pressure
the NHS is under pressure so yes the NHS
is under a huge amount of pressure
crisis well I suppose my argument would
be that if there isn't a plan you might
have a crisis but there is a very clear
plan that the NH NHS has about what it
wants to do it's very clear that given
the impact of covid we do need to
stabilize and recover our ambulance
services our Emergency Services we know
we've got to get through those backlogs
we've already got through the first
Milestone on our backlog recovery plan
and we also know that we need to
increase mental health provision as we
promised we would do in the long-term
plan so there is a plan about what we
are seeking to do and you set out a
number of things uh two of which you've
just mentioned about what you would do
but your essential point is that it is
fixable within the Contours of the
system as it stands well I think it's
really interesting Trevor you know 94 of
the British public say they have strong
support for the NHS model it is based on
this key principle that it has
overwhelming public support that the NHS
provides care free at the point of use
based on clinical need not ability to
pay and that interestingly as again as I
think you know Trevor it's the NHS that
makes us most proud to be British okay
Simon Jenkins it's fixable as long as we
have a plan and we have money
well that's the case I'll buy it
um I think what's interesting now is
that I just sense from that that
introduction you gave there there's a
shift in general perception it was a
religion the NHS which everybody
supported you almost went to church on
Sunday and prayed to it
um somehow that's gone and I think the
reason is that money was always the
answer to the nhs's problems give them
more money and now it doesn't appear to
be the case that they can spend the
money uh and and there are every single
statistic every week it's demoralizing
for the NHS I'm sure it's demoralizing
for the users of the NHS to be told
endlessly this is one of the worst
Health Services in Europe and I've been
studying them in Europe and it's quite
interesting that that in almost every
respect we are not doing as well as
other countries and it seems to me that
we're actually
um stuck and no one knows who the
leadership is and I come back to the
basic point it's a nationalized industry
of huge proportions it's like the Red
Army and it's just me too big and if you
look at successful Health Services like
Denmark's and other services like that
they're smaller they're more broken up
they're more disparate and they do
perform more efficiently
okay well there's two clear positions
one that we can
been in the Contours sorted out another
that actually in the long term may not
be possible let's talk to another member
of viewers panel Josephine Poco
Josephine you work in it and they said I
know you're based you're at the moment
based in Accra but you know and have
worked work in our system and what's
your view yeah
pardon sorry what is your view between
these two points of view which are not
absolutely but broadly speaking that
actually we can make the current system
work better
on the one hand or the view that
actually as whatever you do we've got to
an outfit that is just too big and
unmanageable
yeah so I
can work better I think the NHS is a
great service that Great Britain
provides to people for free so it's no
wonder it's the Envy of the world
however there are problems in the NHS
which need to be fixed so like the
waiting times are a serious problem so I
think to improve waiting times there
should be more GPS and doctors and
available which means um so recruiting
more staff so I think that can be done
by incentivizing people to train those
doctors and nurses like with bursaries
and so on and so um because this is the
case with teachers with teacher training
so it should be the same with doctors
and nurses in the medical profession
Josephine thank you very much just um
talk to Debbie srider in Edinburgh Dave
you're a professor of Public Health and
you studied systems watch your view
about this uh is it fixable
I think you have to look at how we got
into the situation the two things I
would point to our first money we spend
far less on our health care than other
comparable European countries on average
20 percent less and almost 40 percent
less per capita than Germany so we do
have less funding in the system and the
second issue is Staffing we know right
now that one of the reasons nurses are
striking is over safety they say they
don't have enough staff for it to be
safe and part of the problem there isn't
and I hate to mention the word is brexit
we have seen shortages of essential
personnel and just to give you some
numbers if you go back to 2015 we had 10
000 nurses from the EU last year we had
600 and so we are saying that some of
that red tape around visas making it
very expensive for people is leading to
people saying well actually can I work
in Britain as a nurse as a midwife and
that's partially leading to our problem
now around staff shortages and GPS
doctors Consultants as well as nurses
and midwives okay um I'm going to come
back to some of those issues a bit later
Chris Thomas what do you think you
studied as part of your commission you
studied other systems Davey says the
Germans spend more per capita
um are they more satisfied
yeah well I think I think other systems
can teach us a huge amount um if we're
thinking about how we got to the point
that we are now then let's compare the
UK to other countries on the eve of the
covid-19 pandemic and what we see well
compared to countries like Norway we
have less doctors and less nurses
compared to countries like Germany as as
David says we have less money per head
but we also have less beds and actually
the pernicious part of that is not just
that we have less beds it's that we have
higher occupancy in hospitals so they
have less space less capacity to manage
surges in demand and so when things like
pandemics happen or when things like
seasonal winter viruses happen you know
in in years like this year then it's
much much more difficult so there is
that kind of core point of do we have
enough capacity do other countries have
more capacity and that's probably yes
the other big difference between the UK
system and other countries or many other
countries that are comparable is what we
did in response to the 2008 financial
crash and we can't ignore the other
vital Health vital Public Services were
cut from 2010 onwards those are things
that are vital to healthy lives but just
very quickly Chris
taking Debbie's point about the German
system came into being I think 1880 it's
much older than ours doesn't seem to
have the sort of problems that we've
been talking about in fact that's
exactly the point she made ours was only
75 years old it's Universal but it seems
plagued with problems is the Simon right
that actually there's something
intrinsically problematic I don't think
it's intrinsic uh I think there are
demonstrable points from quite recent
memory where the NHS has worked pretty
well let's look at
2007 to give an example public
satisfaction was high Staffing numbers
were pretty good it was a better State
of Affairs I think what's happened is
less that the NHS is different it's that
we have 21st century Health needs and a
20th century model so that's the
catch-up it's not necessarily that
there's something intrinsic in it being
Universal or free I'll go I'm going I'm
going to come back to our viewers
um I think I'd like to talk to Paul
Johnson if um Paul is on
um what do you make of this uh this
debate to Paul
I think we have lost hi Trevor hello
Paul uh Paul we just we're just debating
the question of whether actually what
the NHS needs is essentially being fixed
or whether we've got for a variety of
reasons to a place where the model that
we introduced in 1948 is not uh capable
of dealing with today's challenges where
do you stand on this
yeah so my mother died on the 14th of
November
and
she was at Stafford Hospital
the uh casual scheme was fantastic I
wouldn't have a bad word said about the
NHS at all
um they were absolutely amazing and
although of course you know you can
throw more money at it it was fantastic
um it doesn't really need a mass effect
and I just believe that
it shouldn't be privatized it should be
left alone it's the best free service in
the world
okay thank you very much uh Simon how do
you respond to that uh for some people
it does the NHS hospitals particularly
do something fantastic and that actually
we should stop badgering it and let them
get on with it well we're also agreed I
think I mean it's terrific but not a
good enough
um and I just there's always assumed to
be a dichotomy it's either nationalized
or it's privatized there's a third
option which most systems have and is
localized uh and it's it's the sheer
size then it says what happened in 2008
was very important because it was a
nationalized industry it suffered with
all the other National Industries
um it was not allowed to go local local
authorities were left with the care
sector which was punished because they
were all persecuted by uh austerity
um nothing really worked since 2008
almost all the figures sort of started
going wrong since then and I just think
it's one thing to say as as good people
are supposed to say give it more money
it's got to prove it can use the money
and I think there's so many aspects of
the service that are now ineffective in
all sorts of respects we can go through
them all later on but but everyone said
we should reform the the recruitment we
should record reform the bed you should
reform the care system
unless you're satisfied that the system
is fine it's just it's pointless wasting
money on it Chris Chris Hobson yes let
me just I think just Simon just just
give you a couple of small challenges
the first is um this idea that it's a
single National Health Service and that
therefore it's a monolithic kind of
central bureaucracy that's just not true
because actually what you've got is yes
a National Health Service that sets
national standards but we now have 42
local integrated care boards that
actually have a degree of autonomy to
set local priorities and then you
actually have where the 1 million of the
1.3 million staff were employed they're
employed in 200 different ambulance
Community Mental Health and a hospital
trust that again have got a degree of
autonomy run by their own board so in in
fact what you've got here it seems to me
in the NHS is you have an American
System where you've got all of the
individual providers competing with each
other which actually doesn't give you
any sense of you get a real postcode
Lottery what you've now got in in the
NHS is the perfect place where you've
got National standards but you've
actually got a appropriate degree of
local autonomy for the NHS but not only
can they not do anything about the care
sector which is which is one of the
critical things in NHS at the moment is
the inadequacies of the Care sector
which under under local government
um but also they can't even negotiate
their own wages I mean you say they're
local they're not local it's a
nationalized industry all right but for
something just let's see let's see what
our panel our viewers panel makes of all
of this
um you've been listening to the
discussion that we've been having about
whether the system everybody thinks that
the care that can be delivered by uh the
NHS and its staff can be exemplary in
fact it can rise above exemplary
the question is whether we need more of
what we've got better funded or whether
we need to do something different so I'm
going to ask you to put your hands up if
you answer yes to this question will
more money give us the NHS that we want
those who think that in essence the
issue here is underfunding and uh
resources and not systemic change who
thinks
who has yes to the question
that more money would give us
the system we want well I am genuinely
genuinely last show of the series I'm
genuinely surprised by that actually
Simon it seems that the panel here
agreed with you well I'm not going to
complain
um but but I mean to be fair we need to
say what we're talking about I mean
there are two different sorts of Reform
one is whether you run it uh as we've
traditionally run it and we've always
been proud of it and people go abroad
and say don't you admire our NHS are
they slightly stopped doing that now and
the thing they always comment on is it's
one huge institution it's not it's not
broken up it's not localized not a
medical competition but that's quite
different from reforming its internal
procedures we will talk more about that
um in a later part uh you're watching
the great debate
next we hear from the children's author
and poet Michael Rhoden about why he's
supporting the nurses strikes
[Applause]
I'm Lisa Dowd and I'm Sky's Midlands
correspondent we can reveal that the
driver who hit Harry Dunn is 42 year old
am circulas just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far this
is what they're up against is
back-breaking work
water levels are dropping but no one
knows what impact further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open so
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary in this community I'm
told that everybody knows someone
affected by covid change change seems
tantalizingly close in this corner of
the UK
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the NHS crisis and
asking is it Beyond cure
the Royal College of nursing's strikes
next month are set to be the biggest
industrial action in NHS history but
hundreds of thousands of other health
professionals could also join them on
the picket lines ambulance Crews
physiotherapists midwives Junior doctors
they're all set to ballot in the next
few weeks alongside other healthcare
workers who've already voted to strike
the most admired Workforce in Britain is
now at odds with the government as it
battles to be seen as trusted with the
economy
so how's it come to this
well the children's author and poet
Michael Rosen contracted covid in 2020
and he spent 40 days in a coma before
undergoing months of rehab
he's supporting the nurses strikes and a
little earlier he told me why
well very simply put it's because they
saved my life uh probably saved it two
or three times
um I was in a very very bad State as a
result of coveted infection I was put
into intensive care I was in an induced
coma for 40 days and um at that time in
that time they saved my life
so we're seeing today the staff I know
that you feel very strongly about the
position of the nurses seeing today the
nurses announced having announced that
they are going to be striking of course
there are people who think this is not
whatever the exigencies this is not
something that Health Service Personnel
particularly those who have to look
after patients such as you were should
be doing
well I trust the nurses they've been
pushed to extremes as everyone has said
this is the first time ever they've
taken this kind of action they're also
doing everything they can to protect
patients like me as far as I understand
it intensive care nurses won't be coming
out on strike and also people will be
covering for them in as many ways as
possible
um so I don't think people need to fear
anything what they're doing is flagging
up the plight they're in in a variety of
ways overwork underpay low Recruitment
and also very difficult to keep staff so
you have a constant turnover or churn as
they call it do you genuinely think that
the 19 claim they're making can be
justified in a world where people are
facing cost of living crisis and others
are having to make do with one two three
percent
well nurses are facing a cost of living
crisis uh they themselves that's why
they're coming out on strike some of
them can't feed their families uh some
of them are using food banks
um doing extra time even extra jobs on
occasions so that's that's why they're
doing it so they're part of the crisis
they're not separate from it they are in
the crisis and they're doing what uh
workers everywhere are trying to do
which is to claw back some chance to
have a decent standard of living at the
time of this crisis which in some ways
is created by people making enormous
profits like the fuel companies for
example energy companies enormous it's
just eye-watering profits
um so you know it's not it's not an even
even playing field if you like the thing
is though Michael at some point
somebody's gonna have to pay that money
back you know we're uh we're we're
paying 100 100 billion quid or
thereabouts uh in debt a year yeah and
the point I'm really just making is
there are payments that have to be made
whether it's nurses or teachers or
indeed you and I may not need the 10
uplift to our pensions because we are
relatively comfortable but there are
millions of pensioners who do need it
and that costs too I what I'm really
trying to say is is there a problem here
about choosing one group of people over
those who also need the money
believe so after all I think you're
treading on the on the brink of what we
might call a myth a so-called fiscal
black hole so we've been told over and
over again that there is this black hole
but in actual fact it doesn't exist it's
a it's a forecast it's a it's a belief
if you like or or even a myth where
people are suggesting there may at some
point in the future be a black hole but
that's predicated on the idea that we
won't grow the economy so why not why
won't the economy grow what is it that
the government are believing that they
themselves can't grow the economy in
order to fill up this imaginary whole
that they've created there in their
imaginations so we shouldn't be talking
about Peter playing Paul Paul playing
Peter and that isn't what's going on if
anything it's what I stumbled over
namely one lot being played off against
the other
okay last last point then Michael that
the um uh labor opposition is now
talking about yes more funding but also
reforming the Health Service
um what do you make of that
well any I'm not against any institution
looking at itself and reforming itself I
didn't like the sound of one suggestion
that came over the horizon which was
that supposedly richer people could pay
we would create almost certainly a
two-tier service if we did that the
moment you have people paying and other
people seemingly getting it for free we
have a whole idea of people being
deserving or not deserving and some
people getting better service than other
than others and the whole point of the
national National Health Service was it
is a national health service IT services
the whole nation and that's the way it
should work because that's providing
health for all those in need rather than
those who can pay
right Michael Rosen there let's talk to
Lucy chapcourt who is herself a nurse
and uh Lucy you're preparing to go on
strike by the way I said 90 there I
think actually the figure is 17.6 uh is
the claim
what what is your case here
yeah so what I would say is um apart
from that Michael Rosen is a complete
hero
um I would say that you know I've been
qualified now for 14 years over that 14
years I've never had a real term pay
increase ever
um I started we had a small pay increase
we went straight to a pay freeze
um if we had had real terms pay
increases we wouldn't be in the
situation that we're in today when we
are losing staff we can't retain staff
and um yeah patient care is being
compromised okay thank you very much
Lizzy let's talk to
Chris Roberts
um Chris Roberts is in the Isle of Man
um Chris an old friend of the program
what's your view about this
well Trevor I feel the problem with the
NHS is not Financial at all for me it's
more about tears of middle management
within Hospital settings that are not
only a waste of money but worse still
they actually confuse the system it's
about wasteful working practices coupled
with a waste of materials poor trained
staff bad Communications with the
hospital or GP settings the list is
endless so really my question is is
wasteful working practices more of a
problem
uh you know rather than financial it's
easy to spend other people's money
rather than take care of it yourself
Chris thank you so much for your
question uh and you are posing this to
our panel our wasteful NHS practices the
problem Simon Jenkins
well I mean the wasteful practices are a
problem anywhere
um and I hate to disagree with Michael
Rosen um or for that matter with nurses
um but I do think that nurses are in a
peculiar position for all medical staff
are and I don't think they should be
going on strike and a lot of them feel
that way as well
um it is it is a profession committed to
the patients uh the problem is you've
got a system and I come back to this
point again and again in which in which
they feel they've got an alternative to
go on strike in other words there's not
there's not a an industrial relation
system in the NHS which enables them to
get this case across without striking
and that's what's wrong they shouldn't
be a situation in which the Secretary of
State in Whitehall is deciding how much
nurses should get it should be a matter
for negotiation between local hospitals
local local Health authorities and so on
um the system has broken down that
nurses are going on strike but they
still shouldn't go on strike David
Strader um Simon Jenkins makes the point
that actually the way way that we
organize the NHS now in in and of itself
is the problem and the way that we deal
with industrial relations in the NHS is
an example of of the failure what do you
think
yeah I think it's quite sad that we've
come to this point that you know in over
100 years nurses feel like they have to
strike and I support the strike because
I think that the working conditions for
nurses is now making them feel it's
unsafe for patients and they want to be
heard by the government and this is why
they're saying we won't want to go on
strike but listen to us listen to our
terms they've had almost a 20 drop in
real wage pay over the past 10 years and
these are people who have to go home and
use food banks often or rely on family
members to be able to support themselves
I think it comes down to priorities in a
system and it's strange to me that we
don't have the priority of actually
looking at health care workers teachers
the people who keep our society going
and instead that we prioritize things
like protecting non-dom status just to
compare where I'm from in the states I
live in Britain I still pay tax in the
states as a citizen you have people
living in Britain who actually don't pay
tax here in this country though they
live here through cleaning non-dom
status and so I think they're you know
there are things you can look at where
you say oh there's not enough money well
there isn't enough money is just not
going to the priorities that we need
them to be going to can we just uh to
stick with for a moment there's quite a
lot of agreement with that point but I
want to stick the moment with the issue
that's been raised both on the wall and
by Simon Jenkins about the organization
Chris Thomas
um
we don't see much of this kind of
continuous dispute and friction in uh
France or Germany or in Scandinavian
countries why not it might be an element
of how they talk about Healthcare
Services I think the idea that the NHS
is fundamentally wasteful is a little
bit of a myth the assessments of
international data are that the NHS is
actually quite an efficient system and
it does do quite a lot with the
resources that it has but in other cases
that it's quite expensive to be
underfunded so if you've been through
austerity if funding has not tracked
with demand
then actually
on the cheek then can actually cost more
money can take more time it can be
perverse uh in that way so I think the
idea that that it's inefficient wrong I
also think the NHS is one of the most
under managed systems in the world so
the idea of space for management is a
little bit of a myth as well
um we actually don't have very much
change management capacity so if we're
talking about reform or innovation well
who are the people that are specialists
in doing that they're not really in the
system and we need to bring them in all
right Chris Hopson I know that you're
bursting to get in on this because you
were there but I'm going to come back to
you a bit later on this we've got to go
to the break now you're watching the
great debate up next the crisis in
Social care why are so many patients who
are well enough to go home still stuck
in hospital
[Music]
the
the social care is impacting the entire
NHS and that's been the case for some
time now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the NHS crisis and
asking is it Beyond cure
it's not just getting into hospital
that's so difficult but getting out as
well there are record numbers of job
vacancies and social care system at the
moment itself a mishmash of private Care
Homes and local Authority services
people can't always find a residential
place and local councils strapped for
cash are often unable to provide care
for people in their own homes
so how did the care crisis become so
acute
and can we do anything to solve it
um I'm going to talk to David
Young Who I think has had recent
experience of this David good evening
good evening Trevor
what's your what's your experience
well it's a very important topic
actually Trevor because my brother has
been in Social care for over a year
and his mental health now shows little
sign of recovery and the health system
was unable to support him with
independent living due to you know
Staffing covert issues lack of resources
the whole thing has just become a crisis
so now he's forced to give up his flat
and uh live in Social care for the
foreseeable future
this raises concerns with how that's
going to look
um and you know what kind of care am I
expecting my brother to to have
so really the question is what can be
done to improve social care in the NHS
because this is a real big one
thank you very much David it is a huge
one we've seen a big funding package
David's question is
what can be done to improve social care
um David Thomas we've got a National
Insurance Levy and all the rest of it to
fund social care from your work uh what
do you what do you think the answer here
is
so I think there are two really
important things the first is that we
need more prevention in Social care so
as it stands the UK compared to other
countries has one of the most Acute Care
Systems in the world we are far more
likely to either
do care in hospitals or in people or in
caves in Residential Care Homes we are
far worse than other countries that
providing care in the community
providing care in people's homes and
getting there early so the first most
important thing I think is getting more
care into the community into homes where
it's cheaper and probably actually where
the intervention is earlier and you can
you can make a bigger difference on
someone's life any other it's
flourishing kind of lives what's social
care for at the moment it's a life and
limb service it is there to keep people
going and nothing more in the countries
where it's best and let's take some
examples like in in Holland where
dementia villagers have been created
which replicate people's uh lives the
kind of places they lived that they were
used to it's brilliant it's not actually
more expensive in many cases it's better
value for money but there's nothing like
that in our Care Home sector Chris
Hopson um the social care problem sits
like a great big elephant on the back of
the
uh Health Care System doesn't it well so
I think Chris is absolutely right in
terms of one of the sort of conceptions
we seem to have slightly developed here
is the sort of sense that the NHS and
the social care system is somehow Frozen
in aspic and that effectively all of the
people who work within it aren't
committed to improving and developing it
we've laid out really clearly in our law
NHS long-term plan about the fact that
we needed to ensure that the NHS
innovated and it changed and it
transformed and it's precisely in these
kind of areas so in other words we need
to integrate Health and Social care
properly so that they are a single
service we need to put data in digital
at the absolute heart of what the NHS
and social care does so on the NHS side
of the house for example making sure
that every single trust is an electronic
patient record making sure that you can
all those records join up making sure
that you can access them through your
NHS app so that you can book
appointments ensuring exactly as Chris
has said that we effectively stop being
just a national illness treatment
service we actually go more Upstream in
terms of ensuring that we prevent
illness
well and and you know so Trevor the bit
that didn't surprise me earlier on is
when the the panel basically said that
you know money wasn't by itself the
answer and I think everybody in the NHS
is really clear about that it's not just
the money that's the answer we need to
transform too and Chris is right about
21st century Healthcare we need to
ensure that we adopt economics based
medicine to make sure that we have a
21st century service today I'm going to
come to you but I just quickly want to
talk to Jane McCoy who has a point on
this
um Jane mccoyed
what's your thought what's your point
you wanted to make a contribution here
go on
hi Trevor
yes hi Jane you want to make a point at
this point we're discussing
yeah
people care is like that one said we
need to bring it
it's
I think we're having some trouble with
the connections hey what's um uh you
you've of course experienced the
American system uh which is
way more distributed rather fragmented
and so on
um what do you do you think it is
actually possible to do what both
chrisers have been saying which is to
bring social care and um Healthcare
together because that's in a way your
academic expertise isn't it
yeah I think actually if you take a step
further it's all connected
to care
rely is actually a lot on immigrants
people coming into the country which are
willing to work a very difficult job
long hours very low paid and so I think
there you can't just look at Social and
Healthcare you have to look at our
immigration policies and say how do we
make ourselves a welcoming country for
people who want to work here work hard
contribute to their communities and as
well fill those important roles instead
of demonizing immigrants and saying oh
they're coming in and taking away and
the second thing I wanted to say is I
know they might be unpaid carers paid
cares watching this this is one of the
most undervalued but most important jobs
in the community and I just wanted to
say that we need to recognize that value
and say these are people who are the
glue holding together communities
because caring for someone whether it's
again paid or unpaid at home is really
really difficult work and we need to
recognize that instead of kind of hiding
it and making it invisible
I think there's a lot of support for
that on our viewers panel and we're
talking about a big gap 165 000 people
uh Missing uh to work in the social care
system you're watching the great debate
when we come back is it time to ask
those who can pay fees for some kind of
Health Care to stump up
the nurses United will never be defeated
[Applause]
quite a few weeks ago operators started
to talk to me and say well you know
we're really busy coming up to Christmas
but de-escalating cost electricity bills
um oil in the fat Fry at the moment more
expensive than unleaded petrol so it
looks busy but actually our profits are
really really low we've not had the last
Christmas or the Christmas before that
because of the pandemic and come January
people are saying we're going to have to
shut and I was thinking well you know
what can we do here in Greater
Manchester what kind of intervention is
there I came up with the idea and I
presented it to the to the gaffer Andy
Burnham who backed it straight away and
I was like look here in Greater
Manchester let's create something called
give the gift to going out so your local
family room restaurant your local family
are on Pub your local theater your local
gig venue why not create an experience
why not get a voucher or make a book
again take your uncle out for a pint or
for a meal it's really working the
public got behind it and the best thing
about this is when you hand that gift
over in January you'll probably use it
and so when you hand it over at
Christmas you'll probably use it in
January and that is the quietest period
of the earth hospitality and that's the
period where the staff get the least
hours so it's it's a win-win-win for
everybody across the board let's just
put this in a Christmas card or
something you know I've got a booking on
January the 13th that such and such a
venue I've made it for seven o'clock I
want to take you out for a meal and I
know that the cost of living is is
coming in I get that but you know this
is Christmas and if you can afford 10 20
quid or whatever so towards that give
support your local Hospitality venue
because you know if we don't do that
once they're gone our high streets are
going to look completely different and
we need to do our bit this is the big
the fifth biggest sector in the UK and I
personally think those those bigger
chains that have the banks and the
shelves behind they'll always be here
but it's those smaller family-run
Independence that we really need to
protect and and this is making a
difference in Greater Manchester
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're discussing the NHS crisis and
asking is it Beyond cure
now polling suggests that most people in
Britain still believe the NHS should be
free at the point of use
few want to see a two-tier Healthcare
System
but with increasing demand for services
many are choosing to pay because they
can't get what they want when they want
from the NHS if more of us feel
pressured to pay for our health care for
fear of getting stuck on a lengthy
waiting list what will that mean for the
future of the Health Service let's talk
to Michael Mo Michael you're in
Cambridge
um and I think you've got a view which
rests on your experience in Singapore
actually
yes dropper so um the Singapore model is
all about crop retizing the public
Healthcare Systems so even hospitals GPS
are competing with each other to
increase their efficiency so the World
Bank actually suggested that only they
are running like two percent of the
government expenditure on Public Health
Care instead of like eight percent here
in the UK and so my question is that
should NHS patients pay for some
Services because like the Singapore
model really is all about our pocket
expenses from the patients on GP on
inpatient so on and so forth just very
quickly Michael does it work
it works in Singapore provided that
there are also other like safety nets
and the optional public insurances okay
what do you make of that
um you said that you didn't like very
the American system very much and
we could do more with us if we got money
off the billionaires what about
Singapore two percent
of GDP
yeah no I think you can of course find
efficiencies and Singapore is an extreme
example but I worry sometimes in Britain
that we talk about Private health care
we're working towards a market-like
system like the United States and having
studied that system closely it is quite
a slippery slope because you end up in a
system where people who can pay for
Health Care acts as it like a luxury
good and people who cannot pay for it
end up waiting outside emergency rooms
with their children wheezing and able to
breathe thinking if I go into hospital
I'm going to end up in severe debt of
course there's a middle way through that
but I think it's very dangerous to think
that ghosts going private just going you
know into a kind of a market based
system makes it more efficient the US is
one of the most unefficient inefficient
systems in the world we spend you know
billions literally on admin costs and I
think at least in Britain out of all the
problems we have now nobody's thinking
about medical debt and medical
bankruptcy which is actually on the
minds of many Americans and those who
live across the world and pay out of
pocket for their health care it's not
just in the states it's India it's
across Africa so thank goodness Elise
out of everything else we have to worry
about out now the cost of living crisis
medical debt isn't one of those things
Simon Jenkins I know you want to go
local but could be this sort of proposal
that Michael's talked about be part of
that new a new mix I think it's very
difficult it is it is ingrained in the
British not to pay for the Health
Service on the other hand pledge of
people do pay Ireland pay 50 pounds to
go to a GP the problem with those
systems is you have to have exceptions I
mean Ireland almost 50 of people get it
free and I think I think there's the one
argument for it though is it will
encourage people not to go to doctors
unnecessarily that's a real advantage in
payment at least payment at the point of
delivery Chris and Chris you've got 20
seconds East Chris told us so I finished
on the economics of the fact which is
that we shouldn't put any more barriers
in the way of healthcare we currently
have 2.5 million people in this country
out of the labor market because of
long-term sickness what we should be
doing is not putting barriers up and
putting payment in the way of them
getting access to the healthcare they
need which be making sure that
universality goes further and that they
can get exactly what they need because
actually health is the Keystone of a
good economy and getting them back into
places like work that's the kind of
foundation of the rest of the things the
UK wants Chris Hobson the decision how
the payment works is one for government
our responsibility in the NHS is to be
as efficient as possible which is why 2p
in every pound in this country is spent
on Administration 4p in every pound is
spent in Germany 6p in every pound is
spent in France and of over 10p in every
pound Healthcare pound in the United
States is spent on admin our job to be
efficient we are efficient
all the same though Chris it's not
satisfactory at the moment is it no I
don't think anybody in the NHS wants to
be where we currently are we're under
huge pressure everybody is working as
hard as they possibly can to provide the
best possible care because that's what
the NHS always does and will continue to
do
thank you very much
that is all we have time for this
evening and it just remains for me to
say thank you to our panelists here in
the studio
Simon Jenkins
Chris Thomas
Chris Hobson and from Edinburgh Devi
srider
of course at you at home who've always
been at the center of our conversations
and if you'd like to get in touch with
us for the future email us at the great
debate at Sky dot UK
and for now I want to thank our viewers
panel for your contributions tonight and
by the way right through the series
you've been fantastic and uh thank you
so much wave to you and thank you for
wave to our our viewers and you're at
home tonight was last show in this
series so keep talking and we'll see you
again next time on the great debate
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]